know that personally right  some of the best and brightest chefs off  the strip are hosting their own foodie  fest that's going to happen this weekend  in fact this event has become so popular  that now main street in the downtown  arts district they're going to just  close the street to host vegas  unstripped nearly two dozen of the  city's most acclaimed chefs these are  james beard nominees these are winners  of the show chopped they're going to be  there it is a not-for-profit event so  it's going to be benefiting local  charities again it's this saturday it  starts at 8 o'clock there's live music  too you can get tickets right there at  the door it's very popular so get there  at 7 30. i need to check that out yeah  it's amazing all right denise will